there was a tropical storm heading
towards providencia
and then
overnight it had turned into a category
5 hurricane
you said he was
so scared and to pray for them
and it was like worse than they thought
i last heard from victor last night
about midnight he lives right by the
beach but he was heading to shelter with
his sister in a neighborhood called
bottom house and when i woke up this
morning i still haven't heard anything
i just don't know if like
the roof was ripped off of the house
like i don't know how you would survive
it honestly
i mean i'm just scared
um
category five it's usually catastrophic
it feels like death
just
um
just knowing the destruction that's
happened there
it's
so heartbreaking
[Music]
hey oh
i like really worried i know i'm sorry
oh
you heard from him no
how's your his sister
um no
terrifying um
i don't know how she can function right
now
i mean worst case scenario i i don't
even want to think about it
he was at his other sister's house
on the island you know away from the
water but it's like
it's
just wood house like
so i'm just hoping that they left the
house and they went to something like
you know more like a concrete structure
where would they go
like maybe a community center that
they're supposed to like evacuate to
and there's no way he left the island oh
no yeah no because i was communicating
with him last night
[Music]